هل هو نزلة
برد ، أو أنفلونزا ، أو عدوى في الجيوب الأنفية ، أو مرض كوفيد 19 ،
نظرًا لأن أعراض كل هذه الأمراض
متشابهة ، فقد يكون من الصعب معرفة
الفرق ، فربما تكون الأنفلونزا
شديدة جدًا هذا العام ،
ومن المحتمل أن ترتفع حالات الإصابة بالفيروس إلى دكتور
باربارا باور مع ويكسنر الطبي في ولاية أوهايو.
يقول المركز إن أي شخص يمرض
يجب أن ينتبه جيدًا
لجميع أعراضه ، كما تقول ، إذا كنت تعاني من
سعال جاف ، فمن المحتمل أن يكون سببه covid19
لأن البرد والتهابات الجيوب الأنفية مرتبطة
باحتقان الأنف مما يؤدي إلى السعال الذي
يميل إلى أن يكون أكثر مخاطية ، وقد تكون الحمى
إشارة إلى أن الإنفلونزا تقول إن الحمى يمكن أن
تصاحب كوفيد ولكن ليس
كثيرًا ونادرًا ما تكون مصحوبة بنزلة برد أو
التهاب في الجيوب الأنفية إذا كنت تعاني من ضيق في
التنفس ، فمن المرجح أن يكون هذا
العرض نادرًا ما يرتبط
بالأنفلونزا الباردة أو التهاب الجيوب الأنفية.
كم من الوقت استغرقت حتى
تشعر بالغثيان يقول باور إن التهابات الجيوب
الأنفية ونزلات البرد عادة ما
تزداد سوءًا على مدار يومين تؤثر الأنفلونزا
على الشخص على الفور بينما
يمكن أن يختلف توقيت أعراض covid19 بناءً على
حالة اللقاح والمناعة من
عدوى سابقة يمكن أن يساعد إجراء اختبار الطمع في المنزل
فقط في معرفة ما إذا كنت
إيجابيًا أم لا ثم تحديد
موعد مع طبيبك لمعرفة ما إذا
كنت مؤهلاً  أنت تعرف أن هناك
علاجات معينة يقول باور إن أفضل طريقة
لحماية نفسك من المرض الشديد
من فيروس كورونا والأنفلونزا هي تلقي
التطعيم للصحة الدقيقة.